an intense manhunt is underway this
morning to find two murder suspects who
escaped from a South Carolina Jail on
Saturday
police say tyson johnson and curtis
green may be armed and dangerous
a third inmate who escaped christopher
bolton was captured recaptured overnight
Meg Oliver is outside the County Jail in
Orangeburg South Carolina Meg good
morning good morning investigators
believe this escape was planned and that
at least one officer inside here was
assaulted the three inmates escaped from
the Orangeburg County Detention Center
Saturday night the Sheriff's Department
is not ruling out the possibility they
had help
Tyshawn Johnson was in jail charged with
reportedly shooting and killing a
24-year old and injuring two others
during an armed robbery last year curtis
green was charged for reportedly
shooting and killing a 35 year old man
during a carjacking
both men were awaiting trial for murder
police are warning the public if you
spot the inmates do not approach them
and call for help
Christopher Bolton was captured Sunday
night after a tip led police to his
location at least 18 miles from the
jailbreak it was originally jailed for
possession of a stolen car
now the Orangeburg County Detention
Center has been criticized in the past
for having outdated technology but take
a look at this right next door to where
these men escaped they're building a
brand new facility it will have new
cameras sensors and alarms but this site
will not be finished for at least two
years
John meg thanks